الكلمة التي ربما تصف بشكل أفضل
جهود إدارة بايدن
وسياستها العامة هي طموحة. معظم
مبادراتها، بدءًا من تمويل البنية التحتية
لدعم التحول الأخضر إلى
مساعدة أوكرانيا، كبيرة وجريئة الآن،
ويحاول البيت الأبيض تجميع
جهد كبير آخر من شأنه أن ينجح في حال
نجاحه.  سيغير التطبيع السعودي الإسرائيلي قواعد اللعبة،
فهناك العديد من
التعقيدات التي يمكن أن تعرقل
المفاوضات، لكن إذا تم التوصل إلى اتفاق، فإن
أقوى قوة عسكرية في الشرق الأوسط
وأكثر قوة متقدمة من الناحية الفنية،
ستكون إسرائيل متحالفة مع
أقوى قوة اقتصادية في المنطقة، المملكة العربية
السعودية، التي لا تزال المورد البديل.
من النفط العالمي، كل ذلك في ظل
بنية أمنية أمريكية من شأنها أن تمثل فوزًا كبيرًا
لواشنطن
منذ أكثر من عقد من الزمان. وكانت الولايات المتحدة
تبحث عن دور في
الشرق الأوسط ليس
الدور شبه الإمبراطوري القديم، ومع ذلك يؤمن
المصالح الأمريكية في هذا الأمر.  منطقة حاسمة
تسمح لواشنطن بالتركيز على
التحديات الأكبر التي تفرضها روسيا
والصين من خلال تنظيم تحالف ناعم
بين إسرائيل والمملكة العربية السعودية.
يمكن لبايدن الاعتماد على هذين البلدين
لترسيخ المنطقة اقتصاديًا
وعسكريًا، هناك ثمن بالطبع
وهو المملكة العربية السعودية.  يريد
ضمانًا أمنيًا أمريكيًا
وتكنولوجيا أمريكية لبناء
صناعة طاقة نووية تتضمن
التخصيب المحلي لليورانيوم الذي
لم تسهله الولايات المتحدة مطلقًا في
بلد آخر بالطبع، العديد من الدول ذات
الصناعات النووية المحلية تقوم بتخصيب
اليورانيوم الخاص بها من الهند إلى فرنسا، حسب ما
أفهمه بناءً على  تشير مصادر في
الحكومة الأمريكية إلى أن الجانبين على
وشك التوصل إلى اتفاق بشأن القضية النووية
التي من المرجح أن تشمل
منشأة تخصيب تسيطر عليها الولايات المتحدة في المملكة العربية
السعودية، وبحسب ما ورد فإن المظلة الأمنية
لن تحتوي على
نسخة من ضمانات حلف شمال الأطلسي المادة 5
بل بالأحرى نسخة أكثر ليونة.  الالتزام
بالرد واتخاذ الإجراءات إذا تعرضت المملكة العربية السعودية
لهجوم، سيتطلب ذلك
لغة دقيقة لضمان
عدم الاحتجاج بهذا البند إذا عجل السعوديون بحدوث
أزمة كما فعلوا في السنوات الأخيرة،
فيجب أن يتضمن بعض الضمانات
بأن المملكة العربية السعودية ستلبي
مصالحنا.  فيما يتعلق بسعر النفط، تستثني
المنشآت العسكرية الصينية من اتفاقها الثالث،
وتستمر في تقييم نفطها بالدولار
على افتراض إمكانية التغلب على هذه القضايا، ويجب على
واشنطن أن تفتح
مظلتها الأمنية أمام المملكة العربية
السعودية. والحقيقة هي أنه منذ
مبدأ كارتر عام 1980 الذي أعلن
أن  كان الخليج الفارسي منطقة ذات
أهمية حيوية للولايات المتحدة.
وقد أدركت واشنطن أن
التدخل في الخليج من قبل
قوة معادية من شأنه أن يهدد شريان
الحياة الاقتصادي للعالم الصناعي،
وعندما حدث مثل هذا الهجوم ضد
الكويت في عام 1990، هدد
المملكة العربية السعودية والولايات المتحدة بشكل مباشر.  هل جاء في الواقع لإنقاذ
رياض؟ التحدي الأكبر هو مع
إسرائيل. سيتم إبرام هذه الصفقة مع
الحكومة اليمينية الأكثر تطرفًا
في تاريخ إسرائيل، تلك الحكومة التي تحاول
تغيير التركيبة الدستورية
للبلاد والتحرك لإنشاء
دولة فلسطينية.  أمر
مستحيل ولكن المملكة العربية السعودية والولايات
المتحدة لديهما الكثير من النفوذ. إسرائيل تحتاج إلى
هذه الصفقة أكثر مما تحتاج إليه، وعلى
وجه الخصوص رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو الذي يواجه
احتجاجات حاشدة ومحاكمة مستمرة وتحالف لا يهدأ
من
المتطرفين، إذا عملت واشنطن والرياض
معًا، فقد يحدث ذلك.  يجب على الرياض وواشنطن أن يوضحا لنتنياهو أن عليه اتخاذ خطوات صعبة لإبقاء الطريق مفتوحا أمام التوصل إلى
تحالف أمريكي سعودي إسرائيلي جديد
يمكنه أيضا تحقيق تقدم أكبر بشأن
الحقوق الفلسطينية التي حدثت
منذ
عقود.
ويعني حل الدولتين
تجميد توسيع
المستوطنات اليهودية في الضفة الغربية ووضع حد لإضفاء
الشرعية على البؤر الاستيطانية غير القانونية
وفتح المناطق الخاضعة حاليا
للسيطرة الإسرائيلية للسماح
للفلسطينيين بتوسيع مدنهم في
الضفة الغربية.  يثير غضب
شركاء الائتلاف الأكثر تطرفًا في BB الذين يريدون
ضم الضفة الغربية بأكملها، ولكن هناك
طريقة للخروج من المأزق، كما أشار مارتن إلى أن
سفير الولايات المتحدة السابق إلى إسرائيل
أخبرني أن بايدن يجب أن يقدم لـ BB
صفقة استراتيجية كبرى تتضمن اتخاذ
إجراءات بشأن الفلسطينيين.  تسمح هذه القضية لـ BB
بمعرفة كيفية إدارة ائتلافه
أو كيفية كسره وتشكيل ائتلاف جديد.
ما يقترحه بايدن هو أمر جيد
للولايات المتحدة. لا ينبغي السماح للمتطرفين في المملكة العربية السعودية وإسرائيل
في حكومة نتنياهو باستخدام حق النقض، إذ
يعتمد BB على  فكرة أن
الحكومة السعودية في الواقع لا تهتم
بالفلسطينيين وستبيعهم
مقابل
تنازلات خطابية رمزية، لكنه قد يكون مخطئًا في
هذا الافتراض، وقد أبقى ولي العهد الأمير محمد
بن سلمان رجاله
والمحافظين الدينيين بعيدًا بينما
كان منفتحًا.
ونفذ إصلاحات اقتصادية واجتماعية كبيرة،
فقد لا يرغب في إثارة غضبهم من خلال
التخلي عن الفلسطينيين أيضًا،
وإذا أصر فمن الممكن أن
يدعمه بايدن، ومن
المحتمل أن يوضح بعض أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الديمقراطيين لـ BB أن
ثمن  إن تصديق مجلس الشيوخ هو
حركة حقيقية بشأن حل الدولتين، وفي
هذه الحالة سيتعين على نتنياهو أن
يقرر ما يريده أكثر من
تقدم تاريخي حقيقي في أمن إسرائيل أو
الحفاظ على
ائتلافه المتطرف المثير للجدل.